breaking tonight actually just minutes
ago authorities investigating the
shooting death of a film crew member on
a movie set have now obtained a search
warrant for the phone the cell phone
belonging to alec baldwin the actor was
holding the gun that fired the fatal
shot which also injured the movie's
director again breaking within the past
few minutes correspondent matt finn is
in los angeles good evening matt
good evening brett this afternoon the
santa fe sheriff was granted a warrant
to seize and search alec baldwin's cell
phone court documents reveal
investigators will download a digital
copy of alec baldwin's phone believed to
be an iphone the santa fe county
sheriff's office is seeking more
information in relation to the shooting
death of helena hutchins hutchins was
the director of photography on the new
mexico set of the western film rust
starring alec baldwin hutchins was shot
and killed in october by baldwin when he
fired a gun believed to be a cold prop
gun in a television interview baldwin
has since denied pulling the trigger no
one has formally been charged the santa
fe county district attorney has not
ruled out criminal charges in this case
the film's director was also shot in the
shoulder but he has recovered brett all
right matt finn we'll follow this one
thank you